[Música]
hola saludamos a toda la audiencia de
france 24 muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos y damos inicio a un nuevo
episodio de áfrica siete días de
santiago ariztía y en esta oportunidad
estoy reemplazando a mi compañera
liliana valència para este magazine 100%
dedicado al continente africano la
comisión electoral de uganda declaró a
su mujer es museveni como el ganador de
los comicios presidenciales con el 58%
de los votos pero este anuncio se vio
opacado por las acusaciones de fraude
por parte del principal rival y quien
denunció que se encuentra en arresto
domiciliario junto a su esposa el
primero de enero de 2021 entró en vigor
la zona de libre comercio del continente
africano catalogada y considerada como
la más grande del planeta 54 de los 55
países que conforman la unión africana
hacen parte de este histórico acuerdo
económico
tendremos análisis desde españa y por su
parte túnez conmemora 10 años de la
salida del poder del presidente ben alí
tras intensas manifestaciones su
dimisión hizo parte de una serie de
caídas dictatoriales
en el nombre de la primavera árabe pero
muchos tunecinos aseguran que las
promesas de una mejor calidad de vida no
se han materializado
y comenzamos en uganda donde las
autoridades electorales declararon
lluberes musevini como el ganador de los
comicios presidenciales con el 58% de
los votos y esto pese a las denuncias de
fraude por parte de bobby wine el
principal rival del presidente quien
consigue así su sexto mandato wine
denunció que se encuentra en arresto
domiciliario junto a su esposa mientras
que los funcionarios intentan explicar
cómo se recopilaron los resultados en
medio de un bloqueo de internet
yoweri museveni consigue su sexto
mandato presidencial jugando cerró su
jornada electoral el jueves 14 de enero
en medio de un bloqueo total de internet
protestas denuncias y arrestos la
comisión electoral oficial declaró a
yoweri museveni ganador de las
elecciones presidenciales con el 58% de
los votos frente a un 34% a favor del
principal opositor bobby way quien ha
denunciado que hubo fraude y que está
bajo arresto domiciliario rechazando los
resultados y afirmando que estos son un
intento de manipulación contra el pueblo
de uganda por parte de un presidente que
logra seguir en el cargo que detenta
desde 1986
uganda agradezco al pueblo de uganda y
lo felicito por presentarse en gran
número y votar por los candidatos y los
partidos de su elección poder cambiar al
folk de patines como acciones
al fin creo que esta puede resultar
siendo la elección más libre de trampas
desde 1962 elección de un sustituto
tenemos un informe completamente
diferente y todas las personas que
pudieron observar las elecciones tienen
un informe diferente en general museveni
está fabricando estos resultados y es
por eso que ha cerrado por completo
internet y ha desactivado todos nuestros
números de teléfono el mío el de mi
esposa todos los líderes de nuestro
partido mi mensaje a los ugandeses es
que deben rechazar ese resultado con
todo el desprecio que se merece este es
un intento de manipular las voces del
pueblo de uganda en medio del clima
político que atraviesa el país
funcionarios y observadores electorales
afirmaron que su trabajo se vio
obstaculizado por la interrupción del
servicio de internet y por la falta de
organización en el proceso de votación
top 2 la mayoría de los colegios
electorales que visitamos abrieron tarde
como resultado del mal funcionamiento de
los kit de identificación biométrica de
votantes la entrega tardía de los
materiales electorales y la llegada
tardía de los votantes en botes
mientras tanto el partido de la
oposición pide la liberación de su líder
y exige que éste sea declarado como el
ganador de los comicios hacia las
denuncias los partidarios del presidente
yoveri museveni celebraron en las calles
de kampala la victoria de su líder
político quien llegaría a su sexto
mandato
y el primero de enero de 2021 entró en
vigor el acuerdo de libre comercio
africano que incluye a la zona de
mercados de productos y de servicios más
grandes de todo el mundo
este pacto abarca un mercado de 1.200
millones de personas y un pib en
conjunto de 3.4 billones de dólares de
los 55 estados integrantes de la unión
africana 54 salvo eritrea firmaron el
acuerdo 34 o sea lo ratificaron y al
menos 42 de ellos se han presentado sus
ofertas arancelarias para comenzar con
la integración
previamente hablamos con el analista e
internacionalista camerunés sanz y la
dan que nos explicó cuál es la
importancia de la entrada en vigor de la
nueva zona de libre comercio en áfrica
el pasado 1 de enero entró en vigor la
zona de libre comercio del continente
áfrica un hito histórico y algo muy
importante en el continente africano
porque permite a áfrica tener una
herramienta jurídica a nivel comercial y
también permite teniendo una secretaría
ejecutiva a trascender las fronteras
y presentar eso también como una
oportunidad para áfrica de presentarse
como un interlocutor válido frente a
grandes potencias a nivel comercial
además de ser un bloque es un mercado
que representa más de 1200 millones de
personas con un peak total de 34
billones de dólares lo que representaría
en este caso la zona de libre comercio
más grande del mundo hay que reconocer
también que eso representa un gran
desafío no va a ser los resultados no se
van a ver de inmediato va a ser una
carrera de fondo en la que los expertos
tienen que seguir trabajando porque
evidentemente pues va a haber obstáculos
uno de los obstáculos pues pueden ser
las infraestructuras hay que invertir
mucho en infraestructura para que es de
la efectividad de esa de esa zona del
libre comercio y aparte hay un obstáculo
también hay que tener en cuenta los
acuerdos bilaterales que han firmado
algunos países africanos en este caso
pues los
y acuerdos de asociación económica que
han firmado ciertos países ya nivel
individual con un bloque como la unión
europea esos acuerdos los han firmado
pues países como camerún costa de marfil
o ghana y eso puede suponer un obstáculo
para para esa zona de libre comercio
esperamos que no sea el caso o la
repercusión no sea mayor de todas forma
los expertos están trabajando sobre esto
para llegar a acuerdos que beneficien a
todos los estados miembros de esta zona
de libre comercio continuamos en níger
donde habrá segunda vuelta presidencial
el próximo 21 de febrero esto luego de
que ningún candidato obtuviera la
mayoría necesaria en las elecciones del
pasado 27 de diciembre y la disputa será
entre los dos candidatos más votados
mohamed va son quien lidera en la
intención de votos y el expresidente
mahamane ousmane se espera que estas sea
la primera transferencia pacífica del
poder en el país sin embargo días
después del anuncio presuntos milicianos
yihadistas acabaron con la vida de 100
personas en dos aldeas al norte de la
capital niamey según confirmó el propio
primer ministro de la nación africana
este sería el ataque más mortífero en la
historia reciente del país era
catalogado como el futuro presidente de
níger mohamed bazoum estaba prevista
obtener la mayoría de los votos y ganar
en primera vuelta y obtener un mandato
por cinco años a pesar de que el ex
ministro y candidato por el partido
oficialista obtuvo una mayoría de los
sufragios esta no fue suficiente y
tendrá que encontrarse de nuevo en las
urnas con su rival el ex presidente
mahaman usman en la segunda vuelta en
febrero esto luego de que ba sum se
asegurara un poco menos del 40 por
ciento de los votos lejos del 50 por
ciento necesario para ganar sin importar
quién resulte ganador la población
quiere un líder que tenga a la gente
como prioridad
oramos a la para que escoja por nosotros
el presidente que tenga mayor compasión
por la gente el cual muere presidente
que no traiciona al país ni tampoco la
confianza de la gente
walden eso es lo que deseamos el guard
era ya la ley de felicidad a los pobres
a los campesinos y a los granjeros el
futuro que hay son muchos los retos que
níger afronta las mujeres tienen en
promedio siete puntos seis hijos cada
una la cifra más alta del mundo lo que
representa una problemática para el
futuro si a estos niños y niñas no se
les da oportunidades y trabajo otra
problemática es la insurgencia yihadista
que dejó cientos de muertos en años
recientes y desplazó a por lo menos
medio millón de personas estas
elecciones harán historia será la
primera transferencia del poder entre
dos presidentes democráticamente electos
en un país que cuenta sus cicatrices
tras repetidos golpes de estado y se
cumplen diez años de la salida del poder
del ex presidente tunecino ben alí tras
intensas manifestaciones ciudadanas que
pedían su dimisión y así inició la
llamada primavera árabe hablamos de un
proceso de movilización popular que
terminó con varios gobiernos
dictatoriales en la región el caso de
túnez es considerado como el más exitoso
de las llamadas primaveras árabes
pero pese a haber conseguido avances son
muchos los ciudadanos que consideran que
las promesas de una mejor calidad de
vida nunca se cumplieron y un equipo de
france 24 estuvo en ese país
norteafricano
no mucho ha cambiado durante la última
década en este barrio de catherine esta
localidad cerca de la frontera con
argelia fue uno de los epicentros de la
revolución tunecina aquí fueron
asesinados varios manifestantes y para
esta familia que perdió un hijo amargura
no se va y yo al comienzo en enero nos
escucharon y estudiaron nuestro caso
pero luego se olvidó que fueron los dos
hijos los que trajeron la libertad a
este país la gente está orgullosa de
ellos pero sus padres a ellos nos
hicieron a un lado se lo debemos a
nuestros hijos darles justicia
mi hijo mohamed murió hace 10 años pero
para mí se siente como si hubiera sido
ayer estas calles pueden ser nuevas pero
muchos de los problemas estructurales
tras esa expresión de ira de 2011
permanecen a 50 kilómetros de este
pueblo una carretera nos lleva a esta
aislada localidad desde la revolución
estas montañas han sido escenario de
violencia entre las fuerzas de seguridad
y grupos yihadistas en diciembre el
sobrino de mustafa fue asesinado los
extremistas
sospechaban que ese joven pastor era un
informante
este era nuestro hogar y luego los
terroristas vinieron y lo tomaron
esa es la casa de mi hermano miren tan
siquiera tiene electricidad
en el cómo vive mi madre mi hija no
tiene dónde dormir
catherine tiene muchos mártires de la
revolución y hay hambre en el campo
diez años después de la revolución los
más vulnerables aquí se enfrentan a una
nueva amenaza la pandemia de kobe
19 las restricciones suponen que muestra
falla no puede dar entretenimiento en
las bodas así que por ahora su música es
más que nunca una herramienta de placer
pero no para ganarse la vida
y finalizamos con música de la artista
ecuatoguineano ángel glamour quien está
lanzando al mercado su más reciente
sencillo titulado operada book desde
malabo le envió un saludo a la audiencia
de áfrica a 7 días lo dejamos con él y
con su buena música siga con más en
france 24 punto com que le encantaba
demasiado mi nombre es ángel glamour
artista de guinea ecuatorial del sello
lópez dj music y quiero presentarles mi
nuevo vídeo o vereda vo y quiero invitar
también a todos los espectadores de
áfrica 7 días en el canal france venga
espero que os guste a tomar
evita
sí
qué
no
me llevo
camerún favor de las papas
[Música]
a media mañana la fábrica
en mi viaje a mayer objetivos camas
la bolsa de agua voy
[Aplausos]
demasiado
[Música]